Rockets traded in under a fire I'm gonna
start doing that with my clients hi my
name is Luis Suarez I am a personal
trainer here in Hollywood I am certified
by the National Academy of Sports
Medicine the most respected personal
training program in the United States I
will be reviewing various workouts from
various movies and see if in fact they
are safe and effective hitter with a
sledgehammer
Oh Maddie that requires a lot of
strength oh that's crazy neck exercises
this is like the crazy workouts that you
look at the gym you're like why is I
person doing that I mean that guy looks
great but he doesn't have a box of body
he totally got a total bodybuilders body
he's looking some ice recovery which is
really good for muscle recovery yes when
you're in that 50 push-up you're like
can't do that I could do five more
that's going on right now those neck
exercises I really don't know what
they're good for you want to be lifting
put 45 pound plates with your neck from
1 to 10 I would give this workout in
hate why because it makes you burst
through that wall that you we kind of
have in our brain so you know when again
know if you want to do that that extra
rep that extra squat that's what's kind
of what's going on here so I'm always
down for hitting that wall and breaking
through
yes some agility three arrows inhale
some tomatoes that's some special skills
I don't know that even it's the circle
de soleil guys can do this
[Music]
are you gonna get up to women I mean
perseverance erican utmost about us she
does not give up yeah that's a core
strength those legs that was really
entertaining for my rating from 1 to 10
I would give it a 9
a little exaggerating right so hitting 3
is hitting the tomato with three arrows
but I would recommend this workout means
for me doing giving this exercise
agility or natural progressive
bodyweight exercises are my preferred
way of training yes sledgehammer is does
it for you dope
yes striations
yeah gains bro for your workouts tell us
yes yes I will kick that guy out of the
gym like can you stop dropping your
waist put your weights away dude you're
like that guy that was good though
that was a really good workout I would
give this is I stay from him dropping
all those weights
he's doing a lot of training with chains
I mean weighted pull-ups screaming at
the gym so I everywhere can hear him
you can always count on a girl rocky
movie to get you motivated first your
climbers Universal climber is that gym
equipment in the back of the gym if your
gym has it that no one uses we Rocky's
trade it in under fire I'm gonna start
doing that with my clients yes chopping
wood folks no trading you know the
Russians guys gonna go down he's a one
of those guys you see that gymnast super
buff but I could barely run
I mean crunches I'm pretty sure here
here probably at this age you probably
hadn't already ate at this for doing
those kind of sizes alright he's doing
tips through the machine
but Rocky's doing this for the bag of
boulders fashions of shoulder stability
he doesn't stoppable Oh going up the
hill hello as such it's apply it but he
still could do this you know I'm leaving
I'm gonna go work out
it's fun it's really entertaining rocky
gives us that image of what we can
accomplish anything that we want I have
a tiger I love the scene it was great
from a scale from one to ten I'll give
this a 10 for sure the best example of
functional training with high intensity
doing the same exercises and
progressively overloading your body over
time that's what Rocky's doing yes well
furro doing bicep curls in the office
but still no biceps and body fat at over
30 percent single arm front arm raises
front delt raises but his tricep hurts
just watch out for the goons they'll get
you from a scale from one to ten I will
give this a negative two first of all
he's degree a thousand bicep curls if
you are doing a dozen bicep curls you
need to stop your arms are not gonna get
that big it's better for you to do ten
to twelve reps three times a week stop
at that and have your body rest I
thought that was really fun movie
workouts are great because they motivate
you and they want to get you going to
the gym like I can you know look at the
Rocky movies but just like any gym
workout motivation is really higher the
beginning of the year
january/february but then commitment
starts going down like on March April
May we need to keep our motivation high
in order to see the results that we want
to see that includes with building
muscle or losing body fat or moving well
so you always have to train for what you
want to do
[Music]